Here's a question for you that is somewhat involved,
and I really want to check your intuition.
Suppose we have 5 grid cells as before
with an initial distribution that assigns 1 to the first grid cell and 0 to all the other ones.
Let's assume we do U = 1, which means with 0.8 chance
in each action we transition 1 to the right.
With 0.1 chance we don't move at all,
and with 0.1 chance again we skip and move 2 steps.
Again, let's assume the world is cyclic,
so every time I fall off on the right side, I find myself back on the left side.
The question is suppose I run infinitely many motion steps.
Then I actually get a what's called a "limit distribution"
What's going to happen to my robot if it never senses but executes the action
of going 1 to the right on our little cyclic environment forever.?
What will be the so-called limit or stationary distribution be in the very end?